[Music]
being here two years in a row now I feel
like I've become somewhat of an expert
at everything comic book related
everyone don't laugh at that I was being
serious really an expert yeah no
absolutely when it comes to comic books
superhero movies sci-fi fantasy all
things comic-con there is literally no
bigger expert than this big hunk sitting
right here I'm telling you right now I
really believe that all right well I'll
leave that well then you should have no
problem passing the just invented Comic
Con citizenship test administered by the
director of a little independent film
called Star Wars The Force awakens JJ
[Applause]
Wow
pretty nice I I can't believe you're
doing this you're going minutes this is
crazy oh please you know you might know
a few things about comic books and
movies yeah but your trainings not yet
complete are you ready JJ let's do this
I think I'm ready for this and I think
I'm gonna do a great job what class what
class of starship is the Millennium
Falcon oh come on that's easy a
Corellian YT 1,300 life Raider yes in
the Lord of the Rings trilogy what city
is the capital of Gondor ministereth who
is the star of both guardians of the
galaxy and Jurassic world CGI what is
Vin Diesel's real name truck laser tank
what two movies preceded Star Trek
beyond Star Trek bed and Star Trek bad
complete the sentence Batman and Robin
spider-man and Mary Jane ant-man and
anyone willing to hang out with that man
yes
which 2015 sci-fi film warned us what
could happen if beautiful robots gained
too much power the entourage movie if
there's something weird and that don't
look good who are you gonna call my
dermatologists named the big angry
comic-book character who looks like he's
made of orange rocks Donald Trump
what happens to the male sex drive as
one ages the force awakens Deadpool is a
mercenary with superhuman healing factor
Deadpool is also the swimming venue at
the Rio Olympics
[Applause]
what do you call joss whedon doing
yardwork Joss Whedon Whedon what are
Spock's famous last words in Star Trek -
the Wrath of Khan
see you on the flippity froo kill a
troll take away his internet access
[Applause]
name three fictional doctors dr. doom
dr. octopus and dr. Phil in the Harry
Potter novels what is the recipe for
Polyjuice potion okay recipe for
Polyjuice potion step one at three
measures of flux lead to the cauldron
step two add two funnels and not crass
then stir three times clockwise way of
your hand let it proof for 80 minutes
then add four leaches than two scoops of
lacewing flies that have been crushed
into a fine powder if you will simmer
for 30 seconds on low heat wave your
hand again in three measures of
Boomslang skin one measure of crushed by
corn Horn heat for 20 more minutes
wait for hands second time let it brew
for 24 hours then add another scoop of
lacewing stir three times pantai
clockwise then add the piece of the
person you wish to become and wave your
hand one last time boom Polyjuice potion
and finally am i stopping by to
administer this test was a complete
waste of your time yeah
[Applause]
you